connor i'm not going to waste any time
your first pitch tell me your thoughts
the most devastating force pitch ever
seen in the iconic wrigley field
i'm happy with that i'll take that on
board yeah sir alec mills sinker four
seamer change slider and that big slow
curve ball six and six with a four point
five zero e r a
and a rise dumps one into right center
field so there's his first wrigley field
base hit
and he's aboard leading off the first
inning
two and two
and a base hit to right and then a rise
will go around second and dig for third
base
so buxton pokes one to right field good
two strike approach
and the twins have something started
here in the first inning
got him to chase and buxton is safe
he'll get up and go to third base and
arise will come home
an errant throw by contreras so on a
strikeout mills gets it out but a rise
comes in and buckson ends up at third
base
full count to donaldson it's a mistake
if he missed going in
that's to right field and fairly deep
making the catch in front of the ivy is
trace thompson buxton trots home and the
twins take a two-nothing lead griffin
jacks
chuck's gonna have to stay in his
delivery you know i said earlier i
didn't like when he's trying to throw 95
miles an hour and he's 92 to 93. he has
more control control of his body
but an old lineman yep
ripped into right and that's base hit
falls in front of kepler and ortega
aboard to a lead-off single
swing of the miss there and that's the
breaking ball it looked like a strike
until it broke one down three and two
now one out man at second comes down
early
and that one rolls up along third and
hap's gonna be safe well after some of
the bad luck early in the season i think
he was owed that one maybe a couple more
but on a hot streak right now and he'll
take it first and third one out
drilled in the air out towards right
center buxton
gliding across makes the catch tagging
from third and coming in to score is
ortega
right-hander to right hand of the pitch
by mills
garber strikes out on a slow curve mills
will throw that pitch every once in a
while it's a very slow curveball much
slower than the normal big league
curveball one down here's trace thompson
that's drilled to right and going back
kepler at the wall out of here
trace thompson the other way well he
found a spot where the wind
might be helping a little bit
thompson
with his second and we're tied at two so
two aboard with two outs
and an opportunity for frank the tank
inside and he walked him and they're
loaded bases full of cubs two down and
ian happ at the plate
breaking ball got him nice job by jacks
be the best pitch he's thrown tonight in
the biggest spot of the night so far
we're tied at two
i don't know
that sounds awesome that is hammered
left field forget it oh boy
wilson contreras crushes one and that
quickly it is 3-2 into the teeth
of that wind
[Applause]
2-2 pitch and down he goes swing and a
miss and duffy is out number one
strikeout number four
there's a breaking ball got another
swing and a miss lifted up the upper
part of the strike zone big strike out
there two down one and two
and a breaking ball called third strike
one run an inning allowed by griffin
jacks and the cubs have a lead big spot
here for kevin he can have a strong
finish in his final two weeks
breaking ball dumped into right field of
bank's head donaldson around third and
kepler delivers serving a curve into the
right field corner an rbi single and
we're tied at three gordon with a
grounder to second his first time up
let's hit well to left center field
and into the basket
a home run for nick gordon
going to the opposite field a two-run
home run putting the twins in front
and hat punches one through the left
side
his second hit of the game with two outs
a man aboard so now they're loaded
and a good one got him cubs have left
nine men on through four innings and the
twins have a two right
and it's a fastball hit into the left
field corner rise will hold up at second
and that means bumps and let's hold up
at first on what would have otherwise
been a double bunkston second hit
one sharply to right field one sharply
to left field
talk about donaldson taking what what
you give him the right side is open he's
going to take it
drilled into center field a base hit a
rise around third he'll score
and buxton
goes to second base
jackson had to hold up a little bit i
would imagine to see whether duffy was
going to catch that line drive
they went back inside again to donaldson
this time he was ready for it and it's a
6-3 game two runs matted in for
donaldson and now kepler with runners at
first and second
short center
that'll flop into the outfield for a
base hit buxton will score
and donaldson to third
and the twins get at least two more here
in the bib
there's schwendell now
line to left
and it's over gordon's head
and ortega
to third and then it gets stuck in the
ivy
well the wind certainly was messing with
that one 99.1
on the exit below gordon with the
presence of mind not to go in there
looking for it that kills the play and
saves the run for now but it's second to
third with nobody out swindell keeps his
hitting streak alive this ball blister
chance for patrick wisdom to be a hero
here
the other way and that gets down for a
hit ortega is in schwendell on his heels
frankel score and wisdom comes through
and it is now
and it'll be 7-5 donaldson leading off
the twins seventh inning
donaldson drives it to left center and
deep and off the ivy donaldson digging
for second and here's the throw off line
and donaldson's in with a double here is
ceno need to take advantage of the
donaldson lead-off double
drill down the line and fair into the
corner
donaldson will score
sono rounds first and a big insurance
run for the twins on a pair of doubles
here in the seventh
base hit left field garvers third of the
ball game ceno comes in from third base
good for mitch garver jumping back into
the lineup and driving three sharp
singles i'm here with matteo here with
kieran we're gonna sing the song let's
go one two
three
take me out to the bowl game take me out
with the crowd
for it's one
two
three
let's go chicago
[Applause]
alex colomay has a four run lead as
he'll pitch to the cubs in the ninth
inning
one and
a double play to end the game holdame
faces just three men in the ninth inning
and the twins win the opener nine to
five
you